Welcome to our deep dive for you today into Reza Shakazemi's spiritual ethos, exploring the letters anatomy of a whole society and the sharpest test of any just rule, the claim of the poor.
This is onerous for the governors, but God makes it light for those who aspire to the hereafter.
Today we're looking at a document that is, well, it's over 1000 years old,
but it somehow diagnoses the exact dysfunctions of modern political and corporate leadership.
It really does.
It's almost unsettling how timely it is.
I know, it's striking.
And our mission today is to figure out how a leader can hold immense structural power without that power completely corrupting their soul.
We're going to explore how a ruler's justice flows from his hidden tie to the real, not from any sort of worldly calculation.
Which is such a pivot from where we were.
Up until this point in the text, we've been looking at the inward construction of a leader.
We've examined the
the mastery of anger, the mercy owed to subjects, but now the inward man has turned outward.
He suddenly has to govern an entire society.
Oh, a massive society made of competing parts, competing classes, and totally competing needs.
And this transition, this move from the internal to the external is incredibly fraught with danger.
It's where the true test lies for any person in a position of authority.
Because.
It's one thing to describe the ideal ruler's soul in a vacuum, isn't it?
Just sitting quietly in contemplation.
Sure.
It is an entirely different undertaking to describe the actual grinding machine of state that this ruler must operate, all while maintaining that inner peace.
The letter we are examining is basically attempting to keep these two descriptions from coming apart.
It's a massive wager.
The wager here is that the same conviction which orders a person's inner life
can actually successfully order a whole kingdom.
Provided that the leader never forgets on whose behalf they hold the office, they must never ever mistake the center they occupy for a strength that originates within themselves.
And if you think about your own life out there, whether you manage a household or a small team at work or an entire organization, you've probably felt this tension.
Oh, definitely.
You're placed in a position where everyone looks to you for direction, yet internally you're just acutely aware of your own limitations.
That brings us to the fundamental crisis of the unseen axle.
This is the first governing analogy we find in the text, and it's so vital for you to grasp.
The letter leaves the governor he counsels in what looks like a completely impossible position.
Totally impossible.
He is praised at the exact center of society.
Every single thread of the state runs back to him.
You've got the soldiers, the scribes, the judges, the tax collectors.
They all just revolve around him.
Yet for all that centrality, he is utterly powerless in himself.
Society is a wheel.
The governor is the hub and the classes are the spokes.
But a hub turns only on an unseen axle, joining it to the real.
What is so compelling about this image is how it fundamentally redefines leadership.
It shifts the focus from pushing the wheel to depending on the axle.
I mean, think about the physical nature of a wheel for a second.
It's a great mechanical image.
It is.
A hub is the most important part of the wheel, but it's also the most helpless.
Everything depends on it.
But it depends, in turn, on something it cannot supply from within its own circular boundary.
The hub is just dead weight without the vertical axis connecting it to the absolute.
Dead weight, that's the perfect phrase.
Because we constantly view political or social leadership as a horizontal exertion of force.
We think of administration, policy, decree, manipulation, strategy, all those horizontal actions.
We assume a strong leader is someone who grips the spokes and just forces the wheel forward through sheer willpower.
But all of those horizontal efforts mean absolutely nothing if the vertical line to the reel is severed.
The hub sits at the center of every human relationship in the state, but if that vertical connection is cut, it turns nothing at all.
The classes are the visible wheel.
The axle is invisible.
And only the axle makes the wheel a wheel.
Let's translate that into something deeply practical for the listener.
Imagine a modern chief executive officer trying to steer a massive multinational corporation.
They can pull all the horizontal levers available to them, right?
Sure, they can hire aggressive managers, overhaul corporate policies.
Launch new products.
restructure the entire hierarchy.
But if their unseen axle, their core ethical operating principle, their connection to a truth higher than next quarter's profit margins is broken or dismissing entirely, the whole corporate wheel eventually spins out of control.
It becomes incredibly erratic.
The spokes, meaning the employees, the customers, the stakeholders, they begin to snap under the friction.
The CEO might occupy the center of the organization chart,
But without that vertical grounding, their horizontal power only accelerates the collapse.
And that forces us to ask a very difficult question about the nature of authority itself.
If A leader's power does not come from within themselves, and if their horizontal efforts are useless without a vertical anchor, we simply have to redefine what power actually is.
The text does not allow us to view power as a personal possession.
It's not a prize to be won at the end of a grueling political campaign.
Not at all.
The Imam,
peace be upon him, views authorities strictly as a trial from God.
It is not a privilege elevated over the subjects.
That single perspective carries the entirety of his attitude toward rulership.
He accepted power only as an unavoidable duty.
It was an agonizing burden placed upon his shoulders.
The imagery used to describe this reluctant acceptance is intensely vivid, and it's intentionally undignified.
In a famous sermon, he declares that if God had not taken a promise from the learned that they would not stand by silently in the face of the rapacity of the tyrant nor the hunger of the oppressed, he would have flung the reins of the caliphate back upon its widowers.
He goes even further than that, actually.
He states that this world of political power is as insignificant to him as that which drifts from the nose of a goat.
We really need to pause on that image, the sneeze of a goat.
It is such a jarring, repulsive metaphor.
It's meant to be.
Most leaders in human history, they commission grand portraits of themselves.
statues.
They speak of their office with this towering reverence.
But here, the highest office in the land is compared to animal mucus.
The reins belong to the caliphate, but the withers are the back of the beast he would gladly let run off into the desert.
The only thing keeping him in the saddle is not an appetite for the office.
But A covenant?
A covenant that forbids the knowing person to remain a passive bystander while the strong devour the weak.
Power in this framework, it weighs like a crushing debt.
Let me push back on this framework for a moment and make a strong case for political ambition just to test the strength of this idea.
I mean, doesn't ambition drive progress?
That's the usual argument.
Is it not the very thing that compels capable people to take on difficult, thankless, and exhausting offices?
We structure our entire modern democratic apparatus on the idea that
Individuals must fiercely desire the office in order to win it.
They spend years doing it.
They campaign for years, they raise millions of dollars, they subject their families to intense public scrutiny.
The assumption is that this very desire for power is what fuels their endurance once they are finally sitting behind the desk.
If a leader truly viewed the office with the disgust of a goat sneeze,
Wouldn't they just be completely ineffective, like apathetic?
That is the conventional logic of ambition.
It's the air we breathe in modern political life, but the text overturns it completely.
And we find a striking parallel in Plato, actually, from the Republic.
Oh, that's a brilliant connection.
For Plato, the true philosopher who consents to rule is precisely the one who does not want to rule.
The ideal leader takes office not regarding it as a distinction, not as a crown to be worn, but as an unavoidable task.
They care only for justice as the one indispensable thing the state exists to serve.
Both Plato and the text we're examining reverse the ordinary logic of human ambition.
The office is not a reward the ruler collects for being clever or popular.
It is a massive burden the community lays on the shoulders best able to bear it.
And the best shoulders are the ones that feel its full, terrifying weight
glamorous prestige.
Which brings us beautifully to the second governing analogy, drawn from the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
The ruler is a shepherd who owns nothing of the flock yet answers for it.
That's such a grounding image.
The text states that the blessings of God upon a person do not become immense without the right of God over him becoming equally immense.
Privilege obligates.
This is a profound shift in perspective for anyone listening.
To be granted knowledge or wealth or structural power is not to be handed a treasure chest to spend on your own desires.
It's a claim against yourself.
The more one is received, the more is asked.
A governor is simply an individual to whom a very great deal has been given.
and therefore an individual against whom God's claim runs very deep.
Holding a class of people in trust is to be handed sheep that were never your own.
You do not own the wool, you do not own the milk, you do not own the pasture.
You merely watch over them, knowing that at the end of the day, the true owner will ask you how you kept them.
Were they protected from the wolves?
Did you lead them to safe water?
And this immense burden of answerability dictates every single decision a leader makes, starting with the company they keep.
The letter issues a very specific, uncompromising warning to the governor regarding his inner circle.
He's told to explicitly exclude three types of people from his council.
The miser who will frighten him from generosity, the coward who will make him doubt his own strength, and the greedy person who will dress up avarice as good sense.
The text summarizes this exclusion by stating that miserliness, cowardice, and avarice are diverse inclinations, but they are all united by a single underlying disease.
And that disease is a bad opinion of God.
That sounds like wordplay, how is a bad opinion of God different from plain selfishness?
It seems like we are taking ordinary human flaws, things we see every day in boardrooms and government halls, and elevating them to a grand theological status just to make them sound more severe.
It's a sharp challenge.
But the text makes a profound claim here that we must earn and truly understand.
The term used to describe this condition is su'alzan.
It is a bad opinion of God.
So it's not just a passing feeling.
It is not merely a mood.
It's not a momentary lapse in judgment.
It is a mistaken theology.
It is a catastrophic misreading of the divine nature that quietly produces these vices as its inevitable symptoms.
To put it simply, a small God makes small men.
Let us trace the psychology of that.
Consider the inner life of the miser.
The miser is not just someone who likes keeping their money.
Deep down, the miser secretly believes the universe is a place of absolute
scarcity.
They believe God may not provide for them tomorrow, therefore they must violently hoard what they have today.
They're terrified of running out.
The coward operates on a similar frequency.
The coward secretly believes God may not protect them when they stand up for what is right, therefore they must shrink from duty and hide behind compromises.
And the greedy person secretly believes God has given them less than they truly need to be happy, therefore they must constantly, restlessly grasp for more, stepping on anyone in their path to get it.
Trace each of these vices to its root and you find the exact same false idea of who God is.
The fault is not first in the will.
It is an intellectual dysfunction.
It's a fault in the spiritual understanding.
It is the bitter fruit of a weak, emaciated faith.
To deny God's reality entirely is just the most extreme form of holding a bad opinion of him.
And when a leader surrounds themselves with advisors who operate from this mindset of scarcity and fear, those advisors will inevitably shape the leader's policies.
A miserly advisor will convince a governor to cut funding for the vulnerable, framing it as fiscal responsibility.
A cowardly advisor will convince a governor to ignore a glaring injustice, framing it as political pragmatism.
The advisor's bad theology infects the entire state apparatus.
If we follow that logic to its natural conclusion, the converse must also be true.
A strong, living, expansive faith generates the opposite condition, which is Husn al-Zan.
This is a truer, deeper perception of the divine reality as infinitely abundant and merciful.
Out of that perception, the corresponding virtues grow organically of their own accord.
Character is entirely downstream of belief about God.
Think of it like a river.
If the water at the source is polluted by fear and a belief in scarcity, everything downstream, your actions, your policies, your relationships, they will all be polluted by selfishness and cowardice.
But if the source is pure, the downstream waters bring life.
The person who knows God is fundamentally generous can afford to be generous themselves.
The person who trusts God's ultimate protection can afford the staggering courage required to face down tyranny.
The person certain of God's provision has zero need to hoard wealth.
Advisors who counsel meanness and fear are theologians of a small God, and they will make the ruler's God small too.
The method to acquire these virtues is not just trying harder to be good.
It is to contemplate the divine qualities and let the soul be reshaped by them.
You strive to be generous because God is the generous.
You strive to be merciful and compassionate because He is the merciful and the compassionate.
You never do these things because you imagine they originate in your own brilliance or inherent goodness.
Emulating God's generosity requires A profound self-effacement.
You must balance servanthood with the duty of representing God.
That balance is incredibly delicate.
Servanthood keeps the representative from sliding into the trap of mistaking themselves for what they represent.
It prevents the arrogance of thinking, I am the source of justice in this land.
At the same time, the duty of representing God keeps the servant from collapsing into a paralyzed forgetfulness of the dignity their station carries.
It prevents them from saying, I am just a lowly servant.
I cannot possibly fix these systemic issues, so I will do nothing.
It is a dynamic tension between humility and profound responsibility.
That balance is a form of justice itself.
It's the placing of each thing in its rightful order within the soul.
And this inner disposition is the absolute prerequisite for everything that follows in the letter.
Once the inward disposition is set, and only then, the external structure of the society can be safely built.
We move now from the unseen axle in the hub to the visible spokes of the wheel.
The imam walks the governor through the interdependence of the wheel, spoke by spoke, analyzing the diverse classes of society.
But before naming the specific classes, he gives crucial advice on the faculties required to govern them effectively.
He tells the governor to study long with the scholars.
Those who know the formal rules.
Those who know the letter of the law as fixed in the foundational texts.
But he insists the governor must also converse long with the sages, those who know how to apply those rules.
And that requires the living spirit of wisdom.
Knowing the rule and knowing how to lay that rule gently against a messy, breathing, complex human situation, those are two entirely different competences.
A ruler armed only with formal rules devoid of wisdom is incredibly dangerous.
They become a rigid tyrant of bureaucracy, enforcing the letter of the law even when it crushes the spirit of justice.
Wisdom is knowledge put into practice with compassion and timing.
A truly just society requires both the structural integrity of the letter and the flexible humanity of the spirit.
And with that foundation, the interdependence of the classes is framed as a journey from the outermost defense of society inward to its central axis.
The first spoke of the wheel we encounter is the army.
The instruction regarding the military is fascinating because it defies almost every conventional expectation we have about martial leadership.
The Imam instructs that the commander of the troops must be marked above all by a specific quality called him.
This denotes a steady, unhurried forbearance.
He must be gentle with the weak and firm, with the strong, quick to pardon and slow to anger, sincere in his devotion and pure of heart.
Notice how completely strange that portrait is for a soldier, let alone the supreme commander of an army.
Nearly every quality named is a quality of gentleness.
The martial virtues, bravery, tactical brilliance, physical strength, they're almost taken for granted.
What is specified, what is elevated as the deciding factor for command, or the softer virtues?
Mildness, mercy, the readiness to forgive.
But can a soldier really be gentle and fierce?
Doesn't the defense of a state require a hardening of the heart?
We expect martial leaders to be ruthless in the protection of their borders.
We study generals throughout history who were celebrated for their cold, calculated aggression.
Injecting gentleness into the application of lethal force seems contradictory to the very nature of warfare and state defense.
If an army is gentle, doesn't it just get destroyed by an enemy that possesses no such moral reservations?
It seems deeply contradictory until we look at the shared vision between the Quran and the philosophical tradition of Plato.
Plato grappled intensely with the central paradox of the guardian class in his ideal city.
He asked a fundamental question.
How do you raise individuals fierce enough to defend the state from external threats without their fierceness turning inward on the very people they are meant to guard?
If you create a weapon sharp enough to cut your enemies,
How do you keep it from cutting your own hand?
It's A terrifying risk.
Plato concluded they must be fundamentally gentle to their own people and dangerous only to those who threaten the peace.
The Quran, in chapter 48, demands the exact same equilibrium of those who stand with the prophet, describing them as severe against the disbelievers, yet deeply compassionate amongst themselves.
I have to concede that point.
If gentleness isn't the foundation, strength just becomes indiscriminate brutality.
Without that unhurried forbearance, the military force of a state inevitably turns inward.
History is littered with examples of military coup and police states where the very forces built to protect the citizens end up consuming them.
The foundation of gentleness acts as a necessary regulatory mechanism for the violence inherent in defense.
The ideal warrior is not a tempered brute.
They are a person in whom ferocity and tenderness are both fully present, held in perfect tension, and correctly aimed.
Gentleness is the very thing that makes their immense strength safe to unleash.
From the outermost defense of the army, the text moves inward to the next spoke of the wheel, the judges.
If the army guards the physical borders of the state, the judges guard the conceptual borders of truth and justice.
The portrait of the judge drawn here is one of a soul the world simply cannot bend.
The judge faces two primary unceasing temptations.
First, the intellectual complexity of a hard case, which constantly tempts the judge to reach for the nearest easy answer rather than doing the grueling work of uncovering the true one.
And second, the psychological pressure of the litigants, who will try every conceivable lever of provocation, flattery, and appeal to move the judge off the truth.
The judge must be unflinching before the truth, free from greed, unsatisfied with easy answers, and entirely immune to pressure.
What is so refreshing here is the imam's deeply tragmatic observation that follows this lofty ideal.
He notes, quite bluntly, that such people are indeed rare.
He does not harbor any romantic illusions about human nature.
He knows that finding individuals with that level of incorruptible spiritual bedrock is like finding diamonds in the street.
Because such souls are rare, his response is not to just hope for the best.
His response is purely structurally practical.
Pay them generously.
It is such a beautifully pragmatic approach.
The text is not saying, just hire angels to sit on the bench.
It is saying,
Hire the best humans you can find, but pay them so exceptionally well that when a wealthy litigant tries to bribe them with a luxury chariot or a modern equivalent like a lavish vacation or a lucrative consulting contract, the judge can simply say, thanks, but I already have everything I need.
Remove any financial anxiety so their need for help from others is entirely diminished.
A judge who wants for nothing materially owes nothing to anyone politically.
Only such a judge is safe to trust with a verdict that might anger the powerful.
Incorruptibility is recognized as partly a profound matter of internal character, but also crucially, partly a matter of adequate salary.
For the administrators who handle the state's daily affairs, the bureaucrats and the custodians of public funds, the advice is intensely vigilant.
Test their honesty before employing them.
Allow no partiality or nepotism in their appointments.
And once they are in place, keep watching them.
Any abuse of privilege, no matter how small, must be caught and punished firmly.
Trust is extended, yes, but it is extended with the eyes wide open.
It is never allowed to harden into a naive assumption that an honest person stays honest simply because they were honest yesterday.
Proximity to wealth and unmonitored power has a corrosive, corrupting pull on the human soul, and the system must account for that gravity.
Next, we look at the tillers of the soil, the agricultural class that forms the economic base of the society.
The economic advice given here is quietly, profoundly radical, especially when we compare it to how empires usually operate.
The strict instruction is to let the concern with the cultivation of the land outweigh the concern with the collection of the tax.
Let's unpack that because it flies in the face of modern economic short-termism.
Tax without cultivation starves the very ground it draws from.
A ruler fixated on the immediate tax revenue rather than the harvest, the long-term health of the soil and the farmers,
is literally eating their own kingdom.
It is the equivalent of a modern corporation slashing its research and development budget, firing its most experienced staff, and cutting corners on safety, all just to show a spike in quarterly profits.
It looks like success on a spreadsheet today, but it guarantees bankruptcy tomorrow.
The true wealth of the land is the flourishing of the people who work it, not the sum of coins collected from them in a single season.
The humblest cultivator must have as real and direct a claim on the governor's ear as the most powerful general.
The imam diagnoses the deeper spiritual disease behind a ruined land.
Land falls to ruin through the destitution of its people, and that destitution takes root when a governor's soul is given over entirely to amassing wealth.
The text explicitly says this happens when the leaders have doubts about what endures.
Greed is framed here not primarily as an uncontrollable appetite, but as a blindness.
A person reaches so desperately for material wealth only because the enduring reality of the spiritual world has slipped from their sight.
This connects directly to chapter 104 of the Quran, which warns woe to the one who amasses wealth and obsessively counts it, thinking his wealth will render him immortal.
The hoarder counts coins as though they can purchase permanents.
What looks like a single unjust economic policy over taxing the farmers is actually
the tail end of a much longer chain of spiritual decay.
It begins with a soul that has stopped perceiving what actually lasts.
That blindness gives way to the panic of greed.
The greed gives way to the systemic exploitation of the vulnerable.
And the exploitation gives way, finally, to a wasted, exhausted land and a broken society.
Greed is a perceptual failure before it is a moral one.
Oppression is just its outward inescapable fruit.
This brings us to the merchants and the artisans.
The final names spoke before we reach the center.
The attitude toward them is carefully balanced.
They are recognized as the vital veins through which a society's goods and needs travel.
The instruction is that they should be left to pursue their trades undisturbed.
But peace is not the same as neglect.
The market is prone to its own specific vices, hoarding goods to drive up prices, miserliness, and the subtle cheating of customers through false weights or deceitful contracts.
A trade left entirely
unwatched curdles rapidly into exploitation.
The instruction is to leave them free to innovate and trade, but not unwatched by the eye of justice.
The market is a fantastic servant, but a tyrannical master.
What we're seeing across all these diverse classes, the gentle soldiers, the highly paid judges, the scrutinized administrators, the protected tillers, the regulated merchants, is the classical Ismaili reading deeply present in these teachings.
Faith and the world are one seamless fabric.
Governance is an anatomy of worship.
The proper functioning of the state is not some sect
administrative tasks that you do on weekdays, separate from your spiritual duty on the weekend.
The administration of justice, the careful oversight of the market, the fierce protection of the agricultural land, these are not just good policies, they are profound spiritual obligations.
They are how a leader prays with their hands and their decrees.
This is onerous for the governors, but God makes it light for those who aspire to the hereafter.
We arrive now at the passage the imam most wants the governor to take to heart.
Having mapped the spokes of the wheel, we reach the lowest spoke.
We reach the poor.
This is a class with no resources, no leverage, and no voice whatsoever.
We are talking about the destitute, the crippled, the orphans, the elderly without family, and crucially, those who are too proud to beg.
Their need is entirely invisible to the state apparatus precisely because they will not display in the public square.
These are the people most desperately in need of justice from their ruler.
They represent a treatment for which God alone can excuse the ruler on the day they find
finally meet.
The imam instructs the governor to appoint a specific, dedicated officer with the explicit charge of uncovering these hidden needs and attending to them directly.
This is the sharpest test of any just rule, because no ruler can extract a single ounce of profit from them.
The lowest spoke of the wheel is the furthest from the halls of power and the easiest to conveniently forget.
The charge to institutionalize this level of care, to actively go looking for the need that hides itself in the shadows
rather than passively waiting at a polished counter for the broken to appear and fill out a bureaucratic form, is incredibly profound.
It establishes a historical through line that echoes across centuries.
We see this exact instinct, this exact spiritual mandate pressed into the modern language of global institutions by the Aga Khan across his decades of guidance.
A community, a nation, is ultimately measured not by its GDP or its military might, but by how it treats those with the least standing to demand anything at all.
Real care means
mobilizing resources to search for the overlooked.
The officer appointed by the imam to uncover invisible need is the conceptual seed from which that entire modern ethic of proactive, systemic institutional care grows.
We must honestly concede that the worldly burden of this directive is immense.
The demand to dedicate precious state resources to care for those from whom no political favor, no tax revenue, and no economic advantage can ever be won is, by any horizontal worldly calculus, completely crushing.
It costs resources, it drains time, it demands relentless focus, and it returns absolutely nothing that the state's ledger can measure as a profit.
In the cold, horizontal accounting of political survival, the poor are pure cost.
A ruler whose horizon stops at this physical life will inevitably eventually take the easy Rd.
and let the poor fall away simply because the brutal math of worldly power demands it.
But the text counters that horizontal accounting directly with a startling teaching from the prophet.
He stated in the bluntest possible terms that a people is granted its victory and its provision through its weak.
Let that sink in for a moment.
The sustenance of the strong, the very success of the entire society, reaches them by way of the very people the strong are constantly tempted to
look and discard.
The destitute are not dead weight on the wheel of state.
They are the unseen channel, the hidden conduit through which the society's actual life supply and divine favor is delivered.
When this duty of care is charged with real faith in God's ultimate justice and a real burning longing for the hereafter, it ceases to be a burden to be shed.
It becomes an inescapable, joyous consequence of belief.
What makes this heavy load bearable is entirely the spiritual dimension.
It is only when this physical world is seen transparently through to the next that a fully just attitude toward this world becomes practically possible.
The imam lists the qualities that make the load light in a very specific, deliberate psychological order.
First comes aspiration for the hereafter, setting the ultimate goal.
Second is patience, the endurance required for the journey.
Third is trust in the absolute truth of God's promise.
Placing patience second is crucial.
Once a person genuinely sees the absolute values at stake,
Once they perceive the reality of the hereafter, patience is no longer a matter of gritting the teeth, clenching the fists, and enduring the misery by sheer force of will.
It becomes something entirely different.
It is sustained by grace.
It flows naturally from a living faith rather than drawing from a finite, easily exhausted reserve of personal resolve.
A person who has truly realized this vertical connection cannot be talked out of their duty by any appeal to self-interest or political pragmatism.
Their fidelity to the destitute
does not rest on a calculation that a clever, more cynical calculation could overturn.
It rests on something the worldly calculators cannot even see.
To be blind to this reality is the defining mark of the oppressor.
The oppressor violates the compassion that lies at the very heart of the divine nature.
They are blind to the promise of eternal felicity and entirely deaf to the warning of ultimate retribution.
Which brings the letter's deepest, most transformative theme to the surface.
It is the question of pure intention.
What ultimately sustains a human being in a grueling task that yields them nothing visible?
No thanks, no wealth, no fame.
The answer is that they are no longer acting for the visible yield at all.
The imam draws a famous, brilliant, threefold distinction of human worship.
He says there is a group who worship God out of desire for reward, and this is the worship of the merchants.
There is a group who worship out of fear of punishment, and this is the worship of the slaves.
And there is a group who worship out a profound gratitude, and this is the worship of the free.
The merchant serves for a reward not yet in hand, treating faith as a transaction.
The slave serves to avoid a consequence, treating faith as a survival mechanism.
But the free person serves out of overwhelming thankfulness for what they have already been given.
This highest posture is gratitude for what is already possessed.
The logic of gratitude turns on a striking, beautiful inversion of time.
For the one whose certainty of the reward to come is absolute,
The future has, in a spiritual sense, already arrived.
Chapter 108 of the Quran speaks perfectly in this register.
We have given thee the paradisal fountain of abundance, so pray to thy Lord and sacrifice.
The gift is stated in the past tense.
It is already yours.
The worship, the striving for justice, follows as its natural consequence, not as its purchase price.
This is worship as thanksgiving for a treasure already held in the heart, not a desperate petition for a wage owed.
A person who serves out of gratitude for a good already received cannot be discouraged by the worldly failure of their efforts.
The ground of their service was never the visible success of those efforts in the 1st place.
The Quran gives this posture a living, breathing face in chapter 76, describing those who feed the needy, the orphan, and the prisoner, saying they feed them only for the sake of God, desiring neither reward nor thanks.
They do not even desire the incredibly small human return of being thanked by the person eating the bread.
The gift is aimed past every physical recipient, straight at the real.
This introduces the third and final governing analogy of our deep dive, drawn from an early Sufi master.
A just deed is a lifeless form.
Its soul is the secret of sincerity hidden within it.
A form without a soul is merely a corpse, however perfectly correct its outward shape might be.
The soul of any just act, any policy, any decree is the intention that no human onlooker can possibly inspect.
The just person intends justice for its own inherent sake because it reflects the divine, not for any political reward or historical legacy it might fetch.
I don't buy that yet is injustices fulfilled in the intention just an excuse for a ruler who fails, a way to legitimate real injustice by saying, well, I meant well.
If a leader implements policies that cause actual harm or fails to protect the weak because of their own incompetence, can they simply retreat to the inner sanctum of their supposedly pure intention and claim they achieve justice in the unseen realm?
That seems like an incredibly dangerous license for passivity and systemic failure.
The text guards against that dangerous interpretation vehemently.
And it is vital we understand how.
The sincerity of an inner intention is only proven by ceaseless, unyielding, striving toward its realization in the physical world.
So they can't just rest on their thoughts.
Without concordant, exhausting, unyielding action, the intention is exposed as shallow, hypocritical, and merely theoretical.
The truly just person does not rest content in a warm feeling of good intention, while injustice stands tall in the physical world.
Their effort is as tireless as the reward they believe in is inexhaustible.
Any slackening of that physical effort, any surrender to apathy would expose the intention itself as fundamentally insincere.
So the doctrine does not lower the demand for relentless action.
What it does is remove the despair when honest, grueling action is thwarted by the messy reality of worldly politics.
If a leader acts purely for visible results, then a defeated result completely defeats the leader.
They burn out.
They become cynical.
But if they act to conform their soul to the nature of the rial, the outward frustration of their effort, by circumstance, by political enemies, by the sheer unpredictability of human life, it cannot touch the core of what they were actually doing.
They never despair because achieving a utopia in this fractured world was never the entirety of their aim.
The imam's own life is the ultimate historical proof of this exact principle.
His years of rule were a near continuous succession of bitter conflicts, betrayals, and civil strife.
that prevented him outwardly from enacting much of the systemic justice his vision demanded.
Yet none of it produced in him an ounce of dejection, cynicism, or the smallest slackening of effort.
Piety provides the way out of tribulation.
The text states that for the one who has pious saw towards God, God establishes a way out of tribulation and a light out of darkness.
The way out is not necessarily a political victory.
It is the door in the solid wall of every earthly injustice.
It is the internal light that no darkness of external circumstance can finally close over the soul that keeps its face turned relentlessly toward the real.
And this brings us all the way back to the hidden spring we started with, back to the unseen axle.
The ruler's justice doesn't come from the complex machinery of the state.
It flows entirely from prayer.
All the governor's justice, the fierce gentleness of the army, the incorruptibility of the judges, the self-forgetting care for the poor who can give absolutely nothing in return, it all has to be drawn from somewhere.
It cannot be manufactured by sheer human effort alone.
It drains away under the immense crushing strain of governance unless it is continually daily replenished.
The ruler's justice flows from their prayer.
from the quiet unseen remembrance of God that keeps the vertical axis of their soul open and alive.
That is the still point where the ruler meets their Lord.
This inner sanctum, not the bustling administration of policy, is where the whole of their justice is actually born and sustained.
This is onerous for the governors, but God makes it light for those who aspire to the hereafter.
We've looked at the wheel and its invisible absol, the vital necessity of giving each diverse class its due, and the absolute unyielding claim of the poor at the very bottom of the spokes.
But the true weight of this ancient text does not rest safely in the past.
It demands to be carried forward into your life today.
When you strive for fairness in your own sphere of influence, whether managing a team, raising a family, or navigating your community,
Are you acting as the merchant seeking a return, the slave avoiding A consequence, or the free person acting out of sheer radical gratitude for what you've already been given?